[Applaus]
meine Damen meine Herren hier oben Liebe
landwerrtinen und landwerrte Liebe
Bäuerinnen und Bauern ich habe
aufmerksam allen Reden zugehört ich bin
ja heute auch hier ich habe die Schilder
gelesen ich hatte ja viel Zeit vieles
davon geht mir nah ich sag gleich was
dazu aber ich will auch was zu den
vielen Reden sagen die viele gute
Argumente für ihre Position hier
dargestellt haben eine Rede ist ein
bisschen abgewichen davon und ich will
das ausdrücklich sagen es war die Rede
von dem Kollegen von
landschaftverbindung vorher hier man
kann gerne über türkischen Basar reden
ich habe die Botschaft schon sehr gut
verstanden meine Damen meine
Herren aber ich will ihn auch mal
sagen ich will ihn auch mal
sagen wissen Sie ich war im
evangelischen Religionsunterricht und da
habe ich auch gelernt du sollst kein
falsch Zeugnis reden wieder wieder
deinen Nächsten sie könen ich das gerne
so reden aber wissen Sie ich frag mich
auch ob sie diese reden auch schon
gehalten haben bei früheren Regierungen
als es noch ein bisschen anders
aussah und ich will noch was
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sagen sie haben sie hier sie haben sie
hier versammelt weil sie eine Botschaft
haben und sie wollen doch mir diese
Botschaft mitgeben damit ich hier im
Kabinettstisch sagen kann
und dann wä meine Bitte und mein Rat wir
sollten nicht so reden ich halte das aus
ich war mal Handballtor ich werde dafür
bezahlt das ist mein Job aber wir
sollten weder über den Finanzminister
Lindner noch über den Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz noch über den Vizekanzler Robert
habbeck so reden weil die wollen wir
überzeugen wir wollen die gewinnen und
wir wollen gemeinsam mit denen eine gute
Lösung
finden so und jetzt komme
ich
[Applaus]
und jetzt komme ich wenn sie mich lassen
zu meiner eigentlichen Rede meine Damen
meine
[Applaus]
Herren meine Damen meine Herren ich weiß
dass wenn sie gewollt hätten oder wenn
sie gekonnt hätten wegen den
Sicherheitsauflagen hier noch viel mehr
Traktoren hier noch viel mehr bäuerinen
und B hätten sein können das weiß ich
und ich weiß auch dass sie hier nicht
zum Vergnügen sind ich weiß dass sie se
langen Weg hier auf sich genommen haben
weil jetzt gerade eine Situation für sie
erreicht ist die
Ernstes ich weiß dass sie mit einer
riesen Wut hier nach Berlin gekommen
sind und sicherlich einige ja auch
wütend auf mich als Teil der
Bundesregierung ich stehe hier ich will
das auch sagen ich mach mir da keinen
schlanken Fuß ich stehe hier als
Vertreter der
Bundesregierung es gehört auch zu meinem
Amtes auszuhalten ihn zuzuhören und wer
mich kennt der weiß ich renne nicht
davon sondern ich komme und ich stelle
mich aber ich bitte
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Sie
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es ist klar dass wir nach dem Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts noch mehr
sparen müssen als davor aber eben nicht
unproportional nicht
überproportional und deswegen will ich
gleich am Anfang
sagen ich halte nichts von den
Streichungen in diesem Umfang und ich
habe auch früher nichts davon gehalten
im Gegenteil ich habe in der
Bundesregierung davor gewarnt
Agrardiesel und die KFZ Steuerregeln
abzuschaffen und in dieser Auffassung
hat sich bei mir nichts
[Applaus]
geändert mir ist sehr klar und das war
ja gerade auch zu hören und zu sehen und
vielleicht auch zu riechen was diese
Entscheidung ver folgenende haben kann
deshalb kämpfe ich im Kabinett dafür
dass in dieser hte nicht kommen ich
werde ihn jetzt auch nicht ich werde ih
jetzt auch nicht das blaue V Himmel
runter
versprechen und es nur auf die anderen
schieben das Wort ich weiß dass sie das
nicht mehr hören können das Wort
Steuerprivilegien das klingt ja erstmal
generös als würde man der Landwirtschaft
was schenken aber nach Z Jahren im Amt
weiß ich der Wegfall dieser Regelungen
trifft sie viel andere Branchen die
Debatten gehen in unserem Land zwischen
Stadt und Land sehr weit auseinander die
meisten Landwirte sind an 7 Tagen in der
Woche unterwegs und es nicht nur in der
ernstezeit
nonstop über ihre Belastungen im Alltag
klagen sie nicht sie haben sich den Job
ja ausgesucht was auf sie zukommt aber
die
Aufgabe aber die
Aufgabe dafür Bedingungen zu schaffen
dass sie diesen Job auch machen können
und dass diese Sache sich auch für sie
rechnet und das steht gerade auf dem
Spiel und zwar gerade weil sie ständig
mit neuen Herausforderungen konfrontiert
werden müssen wir in Berlin dafür sorgen
dass diese Herausforderung auch
angenommen werden
kann
diechricht die Nachricht über die
Abschaffung der Diesel beilfe und der
gleichzeitigen KFZ
[Applaus]
Steuerbefreiung Liebe BerufskollegInnen
Liebe
Berufskollegen wir kämpfen aber wir
kämpfen fair Minister östemer ist
heute ich habe ihm einin Respekt gezollt
und dem sollten wir ihn jetzt alle
entgegenbringen ihm zuhören und ihn
reden lassen ich
bin liebe Landwirt
Land die Nachricht über die Abschaffung
der agrardieselbeihilfe und der gichze
KF
Steuerung nicht irgendwann in die S die
plat ohin schlecht geht Klimawandel
Ukraine Vorschriften Preiskampf billige
Konkurrenz aus dem Ausland
alles sie haben es gemerkt meine Damen
und Herren wir haben es sehr lange
versucht weil es sehr angemessen ist dem
Thema wir wollten solange wie möglich
jir zuhören tatsächlich haben wir dieses
Signal nicht produziert deswegen konnten
wir es jetzt auch nicht ändern zumindest
haben wir J Ö mir lange noch wenigstens
gehört wenn auch nicht gesehen zumindest
nicht bewegt gesehen trotzdem eine
solche Situation habe ich in den letzten
Jahren ich weiß nicht ob nie aber auf
jeden Fall ganz ganz selten erlebt dass
sich dort ein Minister auf eine solche
Demonstration stellt wo offenbar die
Stimmung nicht sehr freundlich ist und
das will ich hier als Einordnung schon
noch mal sagen zumindest teilt sich ist
hier ein Teil der Regierung vor Ort
sprechen wir gerne noch mal mit Frau
Fritz stellvertretende
schffrededakteurin von Agrar heute Frau
Fritz sie haben bis eben ja auch im
östem mir gelauscht die Stimmung scheint
uns wir haben das Bild ja nicht von den
ZuschauerInnen gesehen aber die Stimmung
scheint doch sehr aggressiv jetzt zu
sein also ich muss auch sagen ich war
jetzt gerade bisschen überrascht hier
ich konnte gar nicht so viel verstehen
was gesagt hat sind auch sprechköre hier
laut geworden aber auch das war nicht zu
verstehen äh ich find es mutig dass er
sich hier hinstellt
ähm ja aber ganz ehrlich viel zu hören
ist nicht
der Präsident des Deutschen
Bauernverbands hat zwischendurch noch
mal das Wort ergriffen und die Landwirte
ein bisschen zu beruhigen und zum
Zuhören zu bringen was ich rausgehört
habe ist dass auch Jim ötztemier
die Haushaltskürzung im Bereich der
Landwirtschaft nicht mit befürwortet und
ähm viel mehr konnte ich aber leider
auch nicht verstehen hier aufgrund der
Lautstärke kein Problem Frau Fritz wir
haben tatsächlich das meiste schon
verstanden schöstem mir hat das noch mal
wiederholt was er die letzten Tage schon
gesagt hat und wie er sagt er schon seit
Monaten auch sagt nämlich er habe hat er
gesagt im Kabinett klar darauf
hingewiesen dass er davor warne dass
wenn man beide Steuervergünstigungen
gleichzeitig für die Bauern abschaffe
dass das zu ordentlich und zu harten
einschätzen für die Bauern führ würde
wie kommt es jetzt dass das bei den
Bauern offenbar so nicht ankommt und
selbst obwohl jetzt dieser Minister der
offenbar für sie sich einsetzen möchte
und das nach eigenen Bekunden auch schon
getan hat und in der Öffentlichkeit in
letzten Tagen auch schon getan hat wie
kommt es dass diese Minister hier jetzt
trotzdem nicht das Wort erteilt wird er
hat zwar das Wort aber er wird ja schon
in großen Teilen auch
niedergebrüllt ja ich denke da steckt
auch die Geschichte natürlich etwas
dahinter D ein grüner landwisch Minister
in der Branche wir haben viel erwartet
und die Landwirte waren doch glaube ich
enttäuscht am Ende was die Regierung
hier gemacht hat für die Landwirtschaft
oder eben nicht gemacht hat m und ich
glaube wo es jetzt beim Agrardiesel eben
auch drum geht es geht ja darum die
Wettbewerbsverzerrung auch in Europa
eben nicht weiter zu
nach oben zu treiben das ist auch die
Angst der Landwirte jetzt hier wenn der
agradiesel wegfällt oh jetzt wird noch
mal gebut hier hinter uns laut ähm genau
die Stimmung kocht hoch anscheinend
ja vielen Dank Anke Fritz
stellvertretende Chefredakteurin von
Agrar heute vielen Dank ihn für die Live
Einordnung von Vorort vor dem
Brandenburger Tor in
Berlin so leider steht die Leitung ich
gucke noch mal die Leitung leider zu
chem östem mir weiterhin nicht deswegen
schauen wir noch mal auf Joachim
ruckwiete seine Rede dem Präsidenten des
bundesbauernverbands heute etwa vor über
einer
Stunde
Liebe Bauern Liebe
Bäuerinnen sie sind hier vor Weihnachten
aus der ganzen Republik
angereist Vorlaufszeit drei Tage
tausende Bäuerinnen und Bauern tausende
Menschen die unsere Interessen
unterstützen mehrere Taus Traktoren das
ist eine Ansage an die Berliner
Regierung dass das so nicht mehr
weitergehen kann es
reicht die
Demonstration ist vom Deutschen
Bauernverband organisiert
bzw dazu eingeladen worden wir werden
aber zahlreich unterstützt insbesondere
von LSV die hier sehr stark vertreten
sind herzlich
willkommen aber auch freie Bauern
ABL sämtliche etablierten Organisationen
aus der Land und Forstwirtschaft
Gemüsebau Weinbau die Tierhalter alle
sind sie hier in Berlin
um eins zu sagen es ist Schluss es
reicht zu viel ist zu
[Applaus]
viel Bundeskanzler Scholz
Wirtschaftsminister habck und nicht
zuletzt Finanzminister
lindneren
zusätzlich wollen uns Bauern die
Landwirtschaft zusätzlich mit einer
Milliarde Euro per anum pro Jahr mit
höheren Steuern belasten das ist eine
Kampfansage und dies
kampfans
das ist hier heute nur der Auftakt das
ist die Botschaft an die
[Applaus]
Bundesregierung und wir sind nicht nur
hier in Berlin wir sind auch heute schon
vor Ort mit vielen
Traktoren und wenn die
Bundesregierung
diese mutbaren Vorschläge und ich meine
den Vorschlag zur Besteuerung unserer
Fahrzeuge und den Vorschlag zum
akardiesel nicht zurücknimmt werden wir
ab 8 Januar dafür sorgen egal ob es
Winter ist oder nicht dass es einen
heißen einen sehr heißen Januar geben
wird
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir sind schon
belastet mit mehreren 100undert
Millionen Euro pro Jahr an
zusätzlichen Abgaben bzw Kürzungen ich
nenne die Kürzung zur
landwirtschaftlichen
Berufsgenossenschaft
über 70 Millionen Euro die Kürzung bei
der
Gemeinschaftsaufgabe Agrarstruktur und
und Küstenschutz anen 300 Millionen Euro
das ist schon eine massive nicht
hinnehmenbare Belastung aber das was
jetzt vorgeschlagen ist das schlägt dem
fast den Boden
[Applaus]
aus das Ganze steht unter dem Stichwort
Haushalt
wir müssen
sparen schauen wir uns mal den Haushalt
an Deutschland hatte noch nie so hohe
Steuereinnahmen wie jetzt die
Steuereinnahmen sprudeln das ist kein
einnahmenproblem das ist ein
Ausgabenproblem Liebe bauerinnen und
Bauern